happy birthday bmw motorbikes the
munich-based giant hosted a special
anniversary event at its headquarters
with plenty on show for guests
it wasn't always an easy ride however
the two-wheeler division had some
serious obstacles to overcome in the
1970s
there was a time when the market was
dominated by the japanese recalls bmw
bikes executive carl garlinger
they introduced practically every
conceivable model and engine
configuration and segment
and there we were with a two-cylinder
boxer concept a monoculture that could
no longer survive on its own
that wasn't enough for a market we used
to be a leader in
the highlight of the evening a motorbike
incorporating icons of the past and
future developments
the r9t whose name is no coincidence of
course
the neo retro bike has plenty of thrills
without the frills
and comes with an array of customization
options
the r9t is a concentration of 90 years
of bmw heritage explains bmw motorbikes
president stefan schaller it focuses on
the purer side of motorbike design the
minimum needed
bmw's latest machine is also a throwback
to the past the r90s for example was the
first bmw bike to have a designer
involved an important milestone for bmw
it hit the headlines again when the
racing version took steve mclaughlin to
victory in the very first superbike
event in 1976.
this bike had a lot to do with my life
but besides winning the first superbike
race uh it was kind of the last
of the old generation of bikes
and then they became more technical
after this
and there was a period after this period
in the late 70s when the european bikes
fell away and the japanese took over
everything then somewhere in the 80s by
the time 88 by the time a world
superbike then the european bikes used
to come came back but these are this is
what we like to call the old school bike
when you rode it it moved a little it
was not so stable you know it was like a
living being thing you know
harley-davidsons are still like this but
the new modern bikes are much more
stable much more practical and much
safer for sure
bmw
continues to move with the times another
example being the sea evolution electric
scooter a pioneering piece of
engineering
and far from being consigned to history
the gs is one of the old school models
being further evolved to keep up with
the competition it now has a highly
effective combined air and water cooling
system the classic form with the beak
remains
this motorbike division doesn't play the
essential role for the group in business
terms but stefan schaller does see it
playing an emotional role for many
people bmw bikes provides an emotional
anchor when it comes to bmw they say wow
they compete in races they race through
the countryside they have gs's it's a
special kind of motivation
and the 9t is not short on emotional
appeal either unlike the gs with its
practical virtues this model is all
about sheer enjoyment
the engine is a big part of the fun
factor the air-cooled 1.2 liter cylinder
boxer engine generates 81 kilowatts and
120 newton meters of torque
prices for the 9t in germany started 14
and a half thousand euros